toujours en rapport avec les transports
l'institut vd comme implanté sur le
plateau de satory à versailles compte
depuis le 1er avril un nouveau président
antony jo a remplacé rémy bastien à ce
poste pour une durée de trois ans
renouvelable connie joe qui est avec
nous bonsoir bonsoir attirait alors
comment avez vous vécu déjà votre prise
de fonction le 1er avril dans ce
contexte forcément particulier
oui c'est un petit peu compliqué
heureusement on avait bien préparé avec
rémy dans les périodes pré- confinement
les échanges pour pouvoir me m'assurer 7
continuer de présidence évidemment la
difficulté assez de pouvoir rencontrer
les gens c'est de pouvoir les connaître
ce qui est l'imitation à la vitesse à
laquelle je peux prendre mes fonctions
correctement on va dire alors on
s'arrange du nord on peut pour vous
présenter vous êtes diplômé de supelec
vous exercer dans le monde de
l'automobile depuis plusieurs années
vice président en charge de la r&d chez
psa vous êtes également le responsable
du véhicule connecté à la pf à la
plateforme automobile
comment abordez vous cette nouvelle
liste sion dans quel état d'esprit
l'abordez-vous écoutez j'ai toujours
rêvé faire de la recherche ce que je
n'ai jamais réussi à faire ou pas je
lirai réaction à mon environnement à ce
que je faisais à ce que j'ai souhaité
faire un instant t donc là j'ai cette
opportunité de participer à une grande
aventure et franchement avec tout ce que
j'ai pu voir depuis que j'ai commencé
c'est une grande aventure on a beaucoup
de choses à faire mais justement
l'expérience acquise va vous permettre
de mener à bien cette aventure de mener
deux des projets ou à la tête de bd
comme alors en effet la particularité de
virer comme celle la confluence entre le
monde de l'industrie et le monde de
l'université de la recherche
universitaire et donc mon expérience
professionnelle sur ce sujet va être
très importantes oui on rappelle que vd
comme et est implantée à versailles
l'institut regroupe 58 acteurs des
mobilités innovantes et durables
électrification véhicule autonome
nouvelle solution de déplacement
réfléchir aux mobilité de demain
justement est ce que ça prend tout son
sens aussi aujourd'hui dans le dans le
contexte actuel où revient sans cesse
cette thématique des transports
notamment avec ceux des confinement qui
a commencé à écouter encore plus que
jamais parce qu'on voit bien qu'on a on
a besoin de trouver des nouvelles
solutions de mobilité pour ne pas
retomber dans l'est dans les jambes
dégagement se trouvent les problèmes
monstre que nous avons connues de
pollution avec l'automobile omniprésente
donc on a besoin de pouvoir faire la
part des choses entre des nouvelles
solutions mobilité que ce soit de
l'autopartage que ce soit des navettes
autonome que ce soit d'électrification
de l'intégration des véhicules dans une
ville intelligente
il ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
sujets à traiter la mobilité de demain
le véhicule de demain à quels enjeux
justement doit-il répondre à quels
objectifs
alors il de répondre en particulier en
première en première instance un
objectif de sécurité
ça c'est obligatoire on doit toujours
s'assurer de préserver la sécurité des
gens qu'ils transportent et de son
environnement
il doit répondre aux problèmes de
l'environnement limiter les émissions de
co2 donc être un véhicule électrique il
doit avoir la possibilité de redonner du
temps aux personnes qu'ils conduisent
avec la possibilité d'avoir cette
autonomie est également en cette
autonomie améliorant la sécurité du
transport
et puis il doit répondre à des besoins
de dévolution du goût des gens les
jeunes aujourd'hui sont beaucoup moins
attirés par passer leur permis de
conduire qu'il ne l'était il ya 20 30 ou
40 ans il ya d'autres solutions qui
s'offrent à eux et qu'ils préfèrent et
le véhicule de demain justement est au
coeur d'un des nombreux projets qui sont
menés par l'institut bd comme vous
confirmer il ya un foisonnement de
projets en ce moment aussi sur le
plateau de satory à versailles
absolument dont on travaille dans tous
les domaines que je vous ai cités que ce
soit sur l'amélioration de du coût de
possession d'un véhicule électrique
l'amélioration de son autonomie qui sont
vraiment des sujets clés pour pouvoir le
avoir le répandre le plus largement
possible
on travaille sur l'autonomie
l'amélioration de l'autonomie des
véhicules
comment utiliser l'infrastructure
routière pour améliorer l'intégration
des véhicules autonomes dans dans la
route vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
sujets qui foisonnent comme vous dites
et donc vous êtes président point un
mandat de trois ans qui est renouvelable
les grands objectifs les grandes pistes
de ses premières 3 3 premières années à
à quelles sont elles justement alors
effectivement cette amende à trois ans
renouvelable pourquoi pas les premières
pistes sont axées sur vraiment pousser
quelques grands projets qui sont très
importants pour la mobilité en france
par exemple la confluence entre la
filière électronique de puissance et la
filière automobile pour pouvoir faire un
champion français ou européen capable de
rivaliser avec les meilleurs les
meilleurs asiatiques ça c'est
fondamental pour nos véhicules
électriques travailler justement sur la
répartition de l'intelligence entre le
véhicule autonome lui même et son
infrastructure savoir où il est plus
important d'avoir de l'intelligence pour
améliorer sa performance développer
l'humain au sein de du véhicule il est
très important de savoir comment se
comportent les humains quelles sont ses
attentes par rapport à ces nouvelles
solutions de mobilité
lenaria station quels sont les premiers
dossiers qui vous occupe actuellement
alors je travaille sur plusieurs
dossiers en coopération également un
clapet à vous avez si tout à l'heure la
filière automobile française donc un
projet de déploiement de deux circuits
de tests sur la 5g en région parisienne
très important la 5g fondamental pour
pouvoir garantir la communication de nos
véhicules et l'intégration de nos
véhicules dans le réseau un projet de
d'homologation de logiciels
d'intelligence artificielle de nos
véhicules autonome pour s'assurer de la
sécurité des solutions qui sont retenus
et puis ce projet d'électronique de
puissance dont je vous ai un tout petit
peu parlé tout à l'heure qui est quelque
chose vraiment qu'on est en train de
mettre en place et je précise que vd
comme à d'ailleurs lancé une grande
étude sur le comportement et les
attentes des français en matière de
transport une consultation qui est
ouverte jusqu'au 25 mai vous pouvez vous
rendre pour répondre à cette
consultation sur le site qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran merci tony jo d'avoir
été avec nous merci beaucoup
tout nouveau président devait d comme
l'institut des mobilités innovantes
implantée à versailles